et nous allons maintenant partir pour
découvrir le portrait de celui qui sera
peut-être le futur
yannick noah il a 11 ans et christian
réunissent passer une journée avec gaël
monfils une petite montagne de bonheur
simple un volcan prêt à exploser une
soufrière endormi utilise-t-on services
énormes et à pâte que tous les airs dont
passe pas de 2 820 de cela on se
comprend mais loi mais il ya l'instit
gaël et benoît c'est castor et pollux
tintin et milou ce monde mais 98 les
interclubs le club du 12e arrondissement
rencontre le stade français un petit
tournoi un photographe une caméra 11 ans
1 m 60 43 kg classé 15 3 gaël doit déjà
apprendre à tout gérer
forcément un joueur tu sais que tu te
feras filmés photographiés interviewés
et en plus voire par sand cent mille
2000 15000 personnes si un jour tu joues
au volant on est d'accord ou pas eh bien
ça ça ne s'apprend pas du jour au
lendemain c'est progressif
gaël c'est le goût de l'enfance des
rires des jeux quand il joue c'est pour
le plaisir pour gagner aussi dans ses
gestes dans ses yeux un rêve un grand
joueur yannick noah gaël il ne classait
que l'ancien numéro 3 mondial au même
âge
le père de noah est un ancien pro le
papa de gaël idel une vraie filiation
tennistique vois bien faire pas moins 3
mondial
c'est un bon exemple
c'est un rêve pour toi c'est une idole
quoi ça à peu près on y donne et ça
arrête d'être dans les dix premiers
mondiaux à peine 15 ans est déjà suivi
par la fédération à la fin de l'année
gaël devrait être classé 15/1 quatre
grands pour moi cette année quatre
finales avec toujours l'esprit sportif
attend à lyon quand tu n'expliques que
tu as plus donner c'est un petit
relâchement mental il avait joué très
fort samedi quand on veut
fan de champion bon coeur
c'est pour très très bon je pense s'il
s'entraîne bien tous les jours choses
pour arriver à un bon niveau mais toi tu
vas le talonner tu veux même essayer de
le battre
bah je vais essayer je vais je vais
m'entraîner dur pour arriver à son
niveau et qui a combien 20 du mois gaël
c'était pression pression on pas de
pression dans un hamac toujours jouer
son jeu et tu te rends compte du chemin
que tu as encore à parcourir avant
d'être number one toujours être à 100%
mais jamais de nos ponts bête
qu'est ce qui te manque pour arriver à
ce niveau la rigueur quand je pars de
pas tellement joué à kehl les jeux vidéo
et être vraiment rigoureux sur les
étirements après un match
ce jour là le club du 12e arrondissement
à gagner une poignée de main à son
copain gaël est protégé mis en transe
tard leigh génies en herbe
ses parents ne veulent pas l'emmener
dans une école à champions c'est un peu
pourquoi moi je suis un petit peu
réticents par rapport à tout ça parce
qu'en france les gars mais c'est vrai
que peut-être jusqu'à minimes cadets ils
sont bons et après plus rien ils les
laissent comme ça et bon moi je protège
un peu mon fils par rapport à ça en juin
il y a les championnats d'europe pour
gaël avec l'équipe de france va sort dû
suivre les pas d'inclure yeux aîné gaël
et yannick peut-être deux histoires
parallèles
c'est d'une passion d'une famille senn
godard à roissy
j'aime beaucoup de troupes bah j'en
donnerai pratiquement tout à ma mère et
à mon père pour tous les efforts qu'ils
auront fait pour que soit à ce niveau je
garderai une part pour glee à 4 ans
darryl son petit frère vu aussi de
podium
gaël une belle histoire peut être un
futur champion mais cela n'a pas
d'importance
gaël c'est l'histoire d'un pré ados
plutôt sympa au portage christian
réunissent montage de l'artiste frank
perron vous